نعم ، أنا في الخارج لأن
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في جميع أنحاء البلاد ونقص المياه
قد أدى حقًا إلى معرفتك
بأزمة إنسانية في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، حيث أصبح
الآلاف من الأشخاص
يتحركون من خط المواجهة الذي مزقته الحرب.
مواقع للمدن الكبرى مثل
أوديسا حيث يمكنهم على الأقل الحصول على
نوع من الراحة وبعض الطعام
وبعض الكهرباء التي توفرها المولدات
مع مركز استقبال هنا
في وسط أوديسا وكان هناك
حشد كبير من الناس هناك حوالي
خمسمائة إلى سبعمائة  عائلات من جميع أنحاء
أوكرانيا تأتي إلى هنا لمحاولة الحصول على
الطعام والماء ونوع من
إمدادات الصرف الصحي الأساسية ، كما أنها
مركز كبير في الواقع بعض الناس هنا لديهم
بعض الأشياء التي
التقطوها وليس
يمكنني الحصول عليها  نظرة على ما حصلوا عليه من
طيار غريب ، فهذه المرأة هنا من
ملعب دونيتسك أو بلاستر ، وهي واحدة
من المراكز الرئيسية للقتال ، لقد
أتت إلى هنا على بعد عدة مئات من
الكيلومترات وهي "  سأقول
عضلات
منتجة ، حسنًا ، بعض الذرة الحلوة أو بعض
الفاصوليا أيا كان ، وقد حددت
علبة الفاصوليا بعض الزيت أو
بعض الغسيل السائل هنا
معجون أسنان كثير من هذا بالطبع من
آه usaid من الولايات المتحدة ولكن
هناك  المانحون الآخرون من جميع أنحاء
العالم ومن الشركات الخاصة
أيضًا ، كل هذا يساعد في خدش
السطح على الأقل تقديم بعض الدعم
لهؤلاء الأشخاص ، لكن المشكلة الكبرى هي
أن الضربات الصاروخية من روسيا
مستمرة في أن شبكات الكهرباء والمياه
تتعرض للقصف من قبل  الروس وهذا
يعني أنه مع كل يوم يمر
بهذه الأزمة الإنسانية
يزداد هذا النقص سوءًا